so yesterday was day two of donald
trump's second impeachment trial monday
day one was
a full day of debate as to whether the
senate actually has the jurisdiction
to try a former president they decided
yes we do by a 56 to 44 vote
uh so yesterday was sort of like the
first real day with
eight hours going to the prosecution we
saw all sorts of different presentations
including presentations with videos from
um the january 6th riots some of which
we'll review
later video that was previously not seen
video that showed
just how close of a call it was for a
lot of members of the house and senate
avoiding these riotous violent mobs
incited by donald trump and
you would think that even though most
republicans have already prejudged this
impeachment trial most republicans have
already decided
they're going to be voting to acquit
regardless of what's going on
you might have thought that they'd have
at least pretended to be paying
attention pretended to be weighing the
presentations and
making some kind of a decision based on
the evidence that was there
but they had the benefit uh that the
cameras
did not show the chamber at any time
during the proceedings the cameras as we
saw during yesterday's live streams and
much of the media coverage
were focused in quite tightly on
the presenter the various house
impeachment managers
who had turns to speak yesterday and we
were left to rely
on reports of members of the media in
the chamber to tell us what exactly were
senators doing during what
are very long days of presentations and
it turns out that
many republicans were engaged in
everything from drawing
doodles to sneaking in
ipads as chuck grassley reportedly did
in order to be able to read other
material
unclear exactly what it was while the
presentations were going on
a business insider has a nice sort of
compilation of different reports
about this and they say that many
senators were distracting themselves
yesterday afternoon when the
democratic impeachment managers were
laying out the case rand paul
who at many points appeared to be the
only person in the chamber not wearing a
mask
he was doodling and according to one
report drew a picture of what appeared
to be the capital i guess
almost like architectural of some kind
according to reporters in the room
during a long
stretch of the presentation rand paul
wasn't even
in the room but at one point when the
proceedings went to a break rand paul
reportedly ran back in
and gave a note to trump's attorney
david shone that's according to an abc
news reporter
named allison peckerin a cynthia lummus
who's a wyoming republican
at certain points was not wearing a mask
as well manu raju reporting that rand
paul wasn't even at his desk for much of
the 1pm hour that was a key
uh hour of presentations from the house
impeachment managers nbc news was able
to report that senator mike braun
was sleeping during certain parts of the
presentation this is not like
they slept through metaphorically mike
braun was
literally asleep during part of these
presentations
rick scott at one point was looking at a
map
of what appeared to be southeast asia
unclear if he was
catching up on the geopolitical
implications of the borders in asia or
maybe
figuring out where he wanted to go on an
upcoming trip a senator josh hawley who
was one of the main players in voting
against the certification of a number of
different votes on january 6th
at one point was leaning back with his
feet up on the back of a seat
in front of him very remember when
barack obama put his feet up on the desk
in the oval office
and it was a big scandal almost as big a
scandal as when he wore a tan suit or
liked the wrong mustard
and republicans said you don't put your
feet up in the in the oval office well
senator josh hawley
with his feet up on the seat in front of
him in the senate
and uh he appeared to be reading
documents
um unrelated to the impeachment trial
and he said he was reading trial briefs
um so this is i mean listen um
if this were you know a lot of a lot of
republicans have been making the case
that there's too much
about this trial that's not happening
the way a real trial would happen in a
court of law
for example many republicans have taken
issue with the fact that
democratic senator patrick leahy was
is not only presiding over the
impeachment trial
but will also be a juror in that he is
one of the hundred votes
on the conviction or acquittal of donald
trump and
senator patrick leahy also is in a sense
a witness
because he was there on january 6. now
the witness thing would apply to every
single one of these
senators since they were all there on
january 6th so that
seems to be neither here nor there but
one of the other important differences
between a quote real trial in a court of
law and what's going on here is that if
normal jurors were reading on ipads
sleeping reading documents related to
other matters
during a trial they would be removed
from a case and it could even
potentially lead to a mistrial depending
on what the circumstances were
in a normal jury many of the individuals
would be disqualified uh not
potentially because they were so-called
witnesses but because they were part
of the alleged crime that took place
what i mean by that is that many of the
senators that will be jurors
ted cruz josh hawley and others
were actually part of the two-month
campaign
of claiming that the election was stolen
by joe biden from donald trump
that led to the january sixth riots in
the first place they were
essentially part of the conspiracy uh
with the defendant in this case donald
trump so
there's a lot to sort through here but i
would hope
that everybody would be able to see that
sent reports of senators sleeping and
senators sneaking in ipads and say
listen
that's not right even if they ultimately
are going to vote to acquit
they should be paying attention but
unfortunately there are
lots of right wingers defending this
saying it's a kangaroo court
it's a sham it's ridiculous it's
meaningless it shouldn't even be
happening so good for these senators for
literally sleeping through it
um it's stunning that this is what's
going on it's stunning that these are
the hundred
100 of the most powerful people in the
united states and some of them are
napping
literally napping during the proceedings
we'll see today how it continues
i don't expect rand paul to change his
behavior
i don't expect chuck grassley to change
his behavior and we'll get into some of
the meat of what was presented yesterday
which was
truly stunning to see a lot of the
shirts you see me wearing on youtube
are actually made by a company called
teddy stratford
i love these shirts and that's why i
asked them to be a sponsor of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but
most importantly just overall it makes
the shirt
fit much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout